Daybreak over Iceland's reines peninsula
where streams of molten rock and fires
began to flow near the fishing town of
grindvik this is the second time since
November that the houses are standing
empty here it's people had to flee after
a surge of seismic activity Iceland's
civil protection agency has raised its
alert system to its highest level
signaling harm to people communities and
the environment it was only last
remember that the same area was
evacuated of some 4,000 residents huge
cracks had appeared everywhere forcing
the popular tourist destination of the
Blue Lagoon spa resort to shut down as
Rescuers worked quickly to build
barriers to protect the nearby
geothermal power station people were
eventually allowed to return back to
their homes 6 weeks later but it's clear
this seismic activity is far from
over we are working with scientists and
continuously assessing the situation we
are looking at a lava flow model to
understand the volcano and look at what
actions can be taken to protect the
infrastructure that could be at risk
Iceland's location above a volcanic
Hotpot in the North Atlantic means
earthquakes are a common occurrence it
averages one eruption every four to 5
years but this particular part of the
country has experienced five in less
than 2 years causing widespread
disruption and hazards each time the
ground trembles Sonia Gago Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer